stéphane et philippe le vigan bonsoir
alors stéphane en a présenté votre mari
comme celui qui avait choisi de vivre en
opposition à vincent humbert qui lui
avait choisi de mourir alors ils
répondent qu'ils ne sont comparables
qu'en apparence
leur seul point commun c'est d'être
totalement paralysée et muet mais votre
mari refuse cette comparaison il la
refuse complètement parce que il a cette
chance de voir ouais et ça change tout
parce que ça lui permet
non seulement de voir ce qu'est ce
qu'ils nient ce qui est une grande
différence avec un sens mais aussi qu'il
avait créé une fonder une famille que
ses amis
sont restés très proches et très présent
à partir du moment où on a organisé sa
vie en fonction de son handicap qu'on a
trouvé un ordinateur que on a trouvé un
code pour communiquer tout c'est un
petit peu organisés autour et du coup
philippe grâce à ça pour écrire oui l'a
déjà écrit trop quatre bouquins wali
peut lire peut regarder la télé et
choisir son programme peut aller au
cinéma peut aller
au théâtre tout ça important peut se
poser devant un paysage et le contempler
ça n'a quand même rien à voir il dit
demandait la mort serait une insulte aux
miens alors vous avez un enfant depuis
comment ça s'est passé sont normalement
alors philippe a développé des facultés
mentales extraordinaires de par sa
situation
vous dites qu'il arrive à lire dans les
pensées j'ai pas s'il lit dans les
pensées mais il ressent très fort ce que
les gens ressentent pour lui donc ça
induit souvent il s'en moque un petit
peu d'ailleurs parce que souvent les
gens sont très décontenancés devant lui
donc c'est vrai que
le sang tan et le sachant il les
déstabilise histoire de voir s'ils vont
aller jusqu'au bout de ce sentiment vous
aussi vont se découvrir et c'est vrai
que comme ça c'est 14 dernières années
bon on s'est fait des tas d'amis ce que
je n'aurais jamais imaginé stéphane si
philippe vous avez demandé ce que
vincent a demandé à marie est ce que
vous auriez accepté ça s'est pas posée
et c'est vrai que quand ça vous est
arrivé madame on s'est vraiment on en a
beaucoup parlé ensemble
je crois qu aimer vraiment quelqu'un
c'est savoir aussi le libérer est-ce que
je peux poser une question à philippe je
vais lui demander si même comme ça la
vie vaut le coup d'être vécue oui c'est
un clin d'oeil
tu peux en dire plus a dit
m
oh mais c'est
tellement
des différents
v
masson
que
c'est
grand chose
mais pour s'engueuler ça doit pas être
facile détrompez vous arrivez ya
toujours dernier mot façon de parler
il disait que oui ça valait le coup de
vivre et que c'était même si ça n'avait
rien à voir avec vincent lindon et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars 10
tubes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu ce
bleu